thanks dad it has been less than two
weeks since ccsd trustees voted to
terminate the current superintendent but
there's still a lot of uncertainty about
what's going to happen next over the
weekend we learn that there's a chance
that termination could be overturned
madison kimbrough has the message from
the board president tonight
i want to offer an apology
to the community
i want to offer an apology that centers
around our children our students
the community
our educators
everyone ccsd board of trustee president
linda cavazos addressing the public in
an impromptu meeting after several
allegations have now surfaced i believe
it was channel 8
came out with a letter
that was confidential within
the part that had to do with harassment
and bullying
is that an additional 2 million dollars
is being asked by the superintendent
while she didn't confirm if there was
any truth to what was stated in the
letter she clarified that superintendent
jarrah's termination was for convenience
so the trustees are allowed to terminate
without giving a reason as for talks
about bringing dr jarrah back cavazos
clarifies that it was one trustee member
not all who reconsidered their vote in
the matter we have one trustee that has
asked
to bring this back that was on the
prevailing side
four to three
the other two trustees do not have to be
on the prevailing side to make the
request no word on when a possible vote
could happen if that request moves
forward madison kimbrough 8 news now
ccsd trustee katie williams who voted
against the termination from the start
responded to cavazo's comments saying
everything was a lie